- That's one of the things I think that
if there's a silver lining at all,
that that's even to be
said to come out of this
is that people are realizing,
you have to take your
security in your own hands
and you're your own first responder.
I can't tell you how many
people I've talked to also,
who have reached out and said,
"Okay, I'm gonna get my first gun.
"I need to know what
to get and where to go
"and what kind of training to get,"
which is awesome to see.
And I think what is it,
it's like an 80% increase
from this time last year
in terms of the number of
people who have purchased guns
and a huge significant
portion of that is women
because people are watching
what they're seeing on television
and they're watching.
You can see peaceful
protest during the day
but then the sunsets
and you have all the skinny fat kids
in all their black hot topic gear
that come out to burn down buildings,
because that is protected speech,
but disagreement is violence,
and people see this.
(upbeat music)
- Joining me today is radio
host, television personality,
Second Amendment advocate and
author of "Grace Canceled,"
Dana Loesch, welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Glad to be with you
today. Thanks for having me.
- My pleasure.
All right, so just to clear it up,
because it's gonna be
weird in about 10 minutes.
We taped an hour long
interview about three weeks ago
in the midst of the Corona craziness.
And we were stocking some interviews just
because generally things
have been a little nutty
and you never know when
you can get people.
But before we released that,
I wanted to do a quick
10-minute follow up with you
that we're gonna post at the top of
that interview and separately as a clip,
just to kind of get us
up to speed on everything
that's happening with George
Floyd, with the protests,
the riots, racism, gun
rights, the whole thing.
So how's that for an open ended intro?
Where do you want to
start with all of this?
- Oh my gosh,
where to start,
it just feels like the world's on fire,
kind of it does.
And even though it
feels like there's a lot
of discussion and a lot of people
who are not listening.
Everybody wants to be heard.
And that's fine.
I also feel like there's no nuance
and we can't have any,
I feel like people are too
afraid to have honest discussion.
I mean, really, I do.
I feel like people are too afraid
to have an honest discussion
because they don't want
to be cherry picked apart,
nuance is dead and people are gonna take
the absolute worst thing possible.
And they are going to apply that
and misinterpret anything that anyone says
so they can score a point.
And so real, genuine, honest
conversation cannot be had.
We can't even agree on
what the truth is anymore.
So I mean, where do we go from here?
- Well, listen, if only two people
that were perhaps talking right
now had just released books
that in many ways deal
with all of these issues,
wouldn't that maybe have
perhaps, possibly helped?
- I think you are onto something, Dave.
I think you're onto something.
That's a really good,
that's a really good observation.
You're right.
- Okay, so let's start this way then,
what I've seen is that it seems to me
that everybody across
the political spectrum,
almost with no exclusions,
is completely disgusted by what happened
to George Floyd.
They want justice to be served.
They want there to be
a proper investigation,
all of that.
And that there could have been a moment
where we could have come together here.
And instead, I would say bad actors,
mostly Antifa,
sort of combined with Black Lives Matter
have taken advantage.
And now, we basically
are seeing our country
and actually all over the world,
cities that are on fire.
So to sort of turn this to your specialty,
I'm noticing that even here
in the people's Banana
Republic of California
in Los Angeles,
that average people who
never would have thought
about having a gun are suddenly talking
about getting guns.
I have a couple friends that
just got guns this weekend.
You can't get it immediately.
There's still the 10-day waiting period,
but that went to get
guns this past weekend.
Are you at least enthused that people
are gonna take some of their security
into their own hands?
- I am, especially now
that we're being told
that the police could be
defunded, or demilitarized,
or however they're
trying to walk that back.
I mean, that's one of the
things I think that is,
if there's a silver lining at all,
if that's even to be
said to come out of this,
is that people are realizing,
you have to take your
security in your own hands.
And you're your own first responder.
I can't tell you how many
people I've talked to also,
who have reached out and said,
"Okay, I'm gonna get my first gun.
"I need to know what
to get and where to go
"and what kind of training to get,"
which is awesome to see.
And I think what is it,
it's like an 80% increase
from this time last year
in terms of the number of
people who have purchased guns
and a huge significant
portion of that is women
because people are watching
what they're seeing on television
and they're watching.
You can see peaceful
protests during the day
but then the sunsets,
and you have all the skinny fat kids
in all their black hot topic gear
that come out to burn down buildings,
because that is protected speech,
but disagreement is violence.
And people see this.
I mean, I've been talking
to business owners,
business owners
who have sacrificed so much.
And they've been shut down
for I don't know how many,
like three months now,
they barely made it through
the pandemic lockdown.
And now they have to shut down again
if there's going to be
riots in their area,
and they don't want to have everything
that they've worked for
destroyed and they're like,
"Okay, what do I do?
"I need to be able to get a fire,
"I need to get a gun, I need to get a,
"what, do I get a shotgun?"
I've had so many people ask me this.
And I'm glad to see it.
I wish it wasn't under
these circumstances.
I wish that people even
during times of total safety
and security would realize that,
this is a right that
everyone should be able
to exercise no matter where they are
or what side of the
political aisle they fall on.
- What do you make of the meme
that we're sort of seeing
out of the left these days
that you sort of reference there,
which is that words are violence,
but apparently now
violence is in violence.
So we're hearing this
all over the place now
that violence against property
is not violence.
I'm pretty sure that if
someone burned down your house,
you might consider it a violent act.
Am I crazy, Dana Loesch?
- No, you're not at all.
And I'm pretty sure if one
of the people saying that
had their house affected,
had their business
affected and burned down,
they'd probably changed their
mind on that real quick.
That is violence.
That's a weird thing about it.
If you have disagreed with Antifa,
or the far-left on anything,
disagreement itself is so provocative
that it's tantamount to violence alone.
But if you engage in the
actual physical activity
of violence and whether
you're assaulting people
or setting fire to something,
that's somehow protected speech.
And by justifying disagreeing speech
and presenting it as violence,
they're just now fabricating ways
to justify their actual physical violence.
They want to argue
themselves a way out of it.
And that's so dangerous.
I don't like speech being
portrayed as violence, it's not.
Physical violence is violence.
Speech itself is not violent.
It's not anything but speech.
- So I know we talked about
the the silver lining part,
is that people are thinking
about their own personal security
and their family's security.
And that's good.
As a conservative,
are you kind of surprised
that the wake up call
to this was sort of amorphous mobs coming
to people's property and businesses
as opposed to overreaching government?
Because usually conservatives frame that,
"Oh, I've got to have a gun
"to keep government
away from my property."
But this is to keep citizens.
We thought we had police
that could do that.
Now, we've got police
kneeling in the streets.
- Yeah, now I think
that's a good question.
I think some of it too, is.
I do think that some
political parties bear
some responsibility with this.
So in some regard, it is
a little bit government.
But yeah, isn't that kind
of what the Second Amendment
has always been for.
It's that uncomfortable aspect of it
that everyone whispers about
while they all say that it's really just,
it's only about hunting and self defense.
Yes, but also it's to keep
your government in check.
And that's why we're so different
from every other country out there.
And with this, Antifa seems
with all the exposes
going on about Antifa,
I mean, they're now
classified as a terror group.
They act kind of like this militant,
far-left arm of the Democratic Party.
I can't see any candidates
being prevailed upon
to denounce their violence.
It seems like they just kind of pretend
that they don't exist.
In fact, I think some of them had said,
"Oh, no, these are just
like little local groups.
"It's not really an
organized national effort."
But it is.
Yeah, but it is.
- Well, you saw Keith Ellison's picture
with the Antifa book from like a year ago.
He since deleted it,
but this guy was almost
in charge of the DNC.
He lost by a couple votes.
And he's the Attorney
General of what state?
You're not gonna believe it.
Of Minnesota.
- Of Minnesota, yeah.
And he supports Antifa.
I guess it was about two years ago,
I cut a short,
just commentary about Antifa violence
and this was at the height
when everyone was writing
on college campuses
and how dare they bring
in a conservative to talk to anybody
and they were setting trash cans on fire
and busting up windows.
And I played footage of this video
and I was condemning the
violence and the far-left,
who engaged in it and
defended it turned around
and said that I was calling for violence
by condemning their violence.
Because condemning
their violence by itself
is a provocative act.
And we're in an upside
down world right now
where wrong is right, right is wrong.
Everything is awful, cats
and dogs living together.
It's like that line that Bill
Murray had in "Ghostbusters,"
that's where we're at right now.
- All right, so I got one more for you
and then we'll play the
full-hour interview.
For the people that are like my friends,
that I talked about this weekend
who are getting guns for the first time,
what would you want them to know?
What resources would you send them to,
for the people that just their whole lives
have been anti gun
or never thought ever, ever, ever
that they would have a gun in the home
that are now rethinking it,
what's sort of the most,
what's the best piece of
advice you can give them
as they enter into this world?
- They need to get something
that they feel comfortable
shooting first off.
And it also depends on whether or not
this is something that they're
gonna use for home defense
or if they're gonna go get
their concealed carry license
and if it's gonna be something
that they carry.
I have a lot of different firearms
for different purposes,
whether it's my bedside,
I hear something,
my alarm goes off in
the middle of the night,
or if I'm wearing a cocktail dress
and I'm going to an evening event,
there's something else
that it's like shoes,
you gotta have some variety.
But I always say you
can't really ever go wrong
with a shotgun, you really can't.
If you don't have a rifle,
if you've never shot a semi automatic,
if you don't have a handgun,
shotguns, that's always like
a really good first choice.
And the cool thing about gun owners
is that they are so incredibly helpful.
Good law abiding gun owners
all across the country
are so eager to share with you
what they have found works for them
and what doesn't,
what kind of training works really well.
There's all kinds of, like
you have the California Rifle
and Pistol Association out where you are,
some really awesome people
that do really good training,
they're like up to date with everything.
And they have really good
recommendations as well
as to where you can go,
what ranges you can go to.
I mean, people even get it
down to ammo selections,
for crying out loud.
So there's so many resources out
but I always tell people,
if you've never been around firearms,
shotguns are always something
really good to start with.
For handguns, I like to
recommend like a Glock 19,
which is a personal preference of mine,
Sig Sauer P365, M&P.
I mean, there's a lot of
good choices out there.
And a lot of the
manufacturers out there, too,
these all started,
a lot of them are American companies,
American manufactured, American jobs,
and that's one of the
other focuses, I think,
of our issues today
is keeping everything
right here in the U.S.A.
- All right, Dana, thanks
for doing this pickup.
And now I present everyone
else with my interview
with Dana Loesch.
(upbeat music)
Hey, I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin Report,
quick reminder everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and click
that little bell over there
so that you're notified
when our videos come out.
And joining me today is a
wife, a mom, a radio host,
and author of the new
book "Grace Canceled,"
Dana Loesch, finally,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you for having me, I appreciate.
It's good to be with you again.
This is like what, twice in now one month,
this is the most we've ever spoken.
- We had gone years not speaking
or at least not in full
sentences, just through Twitter,
and then I was on your
show a couple days ago
and we booked you just as lockout began.
You were gonna to come
to LA and then lockout.
- I dropped the book right
at the start of a lockdown,
which is perfect timing.
Publishers love that, they love that.
- So you and I both did the same thing.
We both released books in
the middle of a lockout.
How's it going for you,
did they try to stop you?
My guys really wanted us to push
but I was like,
"No, we're getting this
freakin' thing out,
"I can't sit on it anymore."
What was that process like for you?
- Well, it was a little daunting.
I had the first week press tour,
which is always the craziest
when a book is out, that first week.
And I was in New York for most of it.
This was right at the end of February.
And then I went to D.C.
when they were having CPAC
and I had an event there.
And then I was to go
to Northern California,
and then it was to see you in LA,
and then do a couple of
other things in SoCal,
and then I had to go to Minneapolis,
and there were 22 dates that
I had across the country.
And one by one, they all
started getting canceled.
And the first one was in San Francisco,
and then Sacramento followed,
and then my publisher was like,
"I don't think that you
might have like difficulty
"in getting home even if you
fly out there at this point.
"So maybe we should start
canceling some stuff."
So yeah, it was just that first week.
- Yeah, and here we are.
All right, so we're gonna
do this on the Skype
or whatever pipes or wires we're using.
I'm not even sure at the moment,
but we'll go ahead and do it anyway.
I know that most of my audience
obviously knows who you are,
but I think for the
people that maybe don't,
or maybe know your name,
but don't know exactly what you do,
I think they sort of,
"Oh, Dana Loesch, that's the gun lady,"
like something like that.
How would you really,
I mentioned mom and wife
and I took that stuff
from your Twitter bio,
but what do you really sort
of consider yourself first
at a professional level?
- I think professionally,
I mean, just radio host, and
author, and TV commentator
and I have been in politics
for quite a long time.
I actually got started
in college doing opposition
research for Democrats.
And so that's how professionally
politically it started.
And I cover so many issues,
but obviously the Second Amendment I think
is the one that I'm most known for,
just because it's such a personal issue.
And it's something about
which I'm so passionate,
and I know a lot about it
and I shoot a lot and
I have a lot of guns.
And so it just kind of goes hand in hand,
but I think most people
sort of see me in that vein.
And maybe like the devil incarnate.
It just all depends, I think
on my political position.
- Well, speaking of the devil incarnate,
I am gonna read some of the blurbs
on the back of your book
because you did something
actually pretty hilarious
with the back blurbs,
but we'll hold that for just a sec.
So before we dive into guns,
and we'll talk about
all that hot topic stuff
and all that.
What's going on with you and lockdown?
How's life been?
What are you feeling about
how the states are going
about doing things?
As we're recording this right now,
we are holding it for a little
bit, but I just found out
that it sounds like my state of California
or at least my adopted state of California
is now gonna be closed
for another three months,
even though virtually nobody is sick
and everyone's going bananas.
How's it been for you?
What are you hearing from your
audience and the rest of it?
- For me, it hasn't changed a lot
because I'm kind of like
you, I work from home.
But I have gotten busier,
as weird as it is,
because now my kids are home?
My oldest son's in college, and he's home,
which is actually pretty awesome
because he wants to go
into constitutional law.
And so he has a lot of very
politically-charged classes.
And I just look at it as
an excellent opportunity
to set straight anything
that he has unlearned while
he has been in college
and actually show him like
this is how you approached
balanced research.
And this is where you go
and you get a multitude
of different viewpoints,
and iron sharpens iron.
It's been a little hectic
because the kids are home.
But otherwise, I'm kind of a
situational extrovert anyway,
so on that, and it hasn't
really affected me.
And I am really blessed in that regard.
But what has affected me
is hearing so many stories
of people and friends of mine
who own businesses,
and they're terrified as
to what's gonna happen.
And the town in which I live,
we've lost a number of businesses already.
I was talking to another friend
of mine who owns a salon,
and she's terrified about
what's gonna happen.
They can't get those
paycheck protection loans
because some of the banks
won't call them back,
they go with Chase Bank,
they're not hearing back from Chase Bank.
And that's not like the exception,
that seems to be sort of the general rule
with these situations.
It's really hard for
some of these businesses
to hear back from some of
these banks and to just get.
When you consider that these
people have had their ability
to engage in commerce,
it really is a quasi eminent domain.
There's no other better
way I can describe it.
And their ability to
generate income and to engage
in commerce has been seized.
And they're told,
"Well, we'll provide for
your needs temporarily,"
but then they're not
able to even access that.
It's really rough.
And I don't think that people,
you're talking about LA County,
maybe going under an additional
three months of lockdown.
I don't think that that's gonna happen.
They can't survive like
that, people cannot survive.
- What do you make of
our public officials,
what I would basically
say is like an inability
to talk to us in a mature way,
like, even when I just heard
this three-month thing,
which it sounds like it's
still we're not totally sure.
But like they're floating out this idea.
It's like they don't tell
us why they're doing things.
They don't say, oh, these things.
These policies have worked here.
These policies haven't worked here.
They don't say, oh, we
haven't found any cases
that are killing people
and people under 40 that
are otherwise healthy,
but we know it's affecting people over 80.
There's just no sense making coming out
of almost anyone at a political level.
And I don't mean everybody,
I think Greg Abbott in Texas
is doing a pretty nice job.
There are a couple people doing it.
But that's so many of our
political leaders think
that just because they say something,
that that sort of is divine right
just then and there.
- Yeah, and a lot of those orders
that you mentioned,
I mean, they're not law per
se as one thinks of law.
I mean, they don't have
the force or effect
of law traditionally,
something passed by state legislatures
or something passed by Congress.
And Newsom is weird,
your Governor's weird because he started
out kind of doing okay.
And then he lost his
senses and then he decided
to punish Orange County.
And you're right,
there is a little bit of
nannying going on there
in terms of the way that they
speak to you about things.
I feel like we're not kids,
we fund you.
We pay your salaries,
we're responsible enough
to understand why it
is you're telling us these things,
similar to in the very beginning,
when they were telling folks,
you don't need to wear masks.
Don't worry about wearing masks.
Definitely don't go and get those N95s
or any surgical masks.
You guys don't need those.
It's not gonna stop it.
It turns out they were just
terrified that everybody
was gonna rush to buy those masks.
And after that nobody wanted to believe
what any of these leaders
were telling us anymore,
because if they're gonna lie
about something like that,
what else would they misconstrue?
- And not only that,
but if you were to put
a video out right now,
if we told people not to wear masks,
our videos would be taken down on YouTube
even though the WHO was
saying that very same thing,
just a couple weeks ago.
So I know we're like-minded
on the liberty side of things
and we believe in the constitution,
I mean real political radicals here.
But for the liberty minded people
that do want to figure
out a way to put food
on their family's table,
that want to figure out a
way to go to work again,
or literally even I was
saying to David last night,
I would like to invite
friends over for dinner,
friends that I know
have been in quarantine,
they're healthy, like
not criminal activity,
but like we just have
friends over for dinner.
But what do you think the
liberty-minded people,
like what are the best tactics
that we should be doing
as we try to push on the government
as opposed to just like running around
and just masks off and holding like,
do you see a way we can do this sensibly
if the government is
not gonna do it for us
or something like that?
- Yeah. No, I think
that's a good question.
I love the story of Shelley Luther,
the salon that's maybe
like 45 minutes to me.
She really had reduced
the salon's capacity.
She was following all of the guidelines
that all the medical
professionals were putting out.
She wasn't doing it as a stunt.
But she legitimately was another one
of those business owners
where she couldn't go
and get any kind of loan,
any kind of help.
She has three kids, single mom,
she had a rent to pay for her business.
I mean, she really
needed to generate income
the best way she could.
I love the civil
disobedience aspect of it.
Here's one of the things
that really bugs me
about the mantra from
the house arrest people.
I can't even bring myself
to call it lockdown anymore.
They think that it is that
the law mandating everyone
or what they profess to be law mandating
that everybody stay home is
just because it is a law,
or they perceive it to be a law.
And that it's not because it's right,
or because it's just,
or ethical, or moral.
It derives all of its power from the fact
that it is a law which seems
really ridiculously cyclical
and I don't really think
that they have a good
understanding of that.
So I like the civil
disobedience aspect of it.
I was telling a friend of mine,
I am totally into the
speakeasy culture now.
I'm all about let's do it speakeasy style
and I was even telling a friend of mine
who works with the governor here in Texas.
I'm like, "I'm going to just do speakeasy,
"y'all can come at me."
Come and make me instead of,
come and take it, come and make me
and just have like speakeasy salon,
I haven't had a hair
trim in like 10 weeks.
I know it's first-world problems.
But just to kind of get
back to normal a little bit
and also give people a
way to earn some money.
But the state has been,
they've actually been kind of clever,
in that they were threatening
a lot of the hairdressers
and cosmetologist with the
removal of their licenses.
So they do have to be careful
because you always have that.
I call it that one turd in the punch bowl
that always ruins everything.
They always want to go
tell on the government,
someone is cutting hair against
the lockdown regulations,
we're gonna go tell the police,
we're gonna go tell the licensing office
and we're gonna have their license pulled.
It's ridiculous.
And so I like the civil disobedience.
But I jokingly say that the more
that the state pushes against the people.
I'm not saying that's
how you get a boogaloo.
But I'm saying that
might be how you get one
if you keep up those measures.
- Yeah, well, speaking of shorter hair,
I'm not saying that my hair
is shorter than it was,
say three days ago,
but maybe it is, I'm just saying,
I'm not really saying anything,
but maybe it is, maybe it isn't.
What do you think this
says about generally like,
for those of us that are
worried about authoritarianism,
for those of us that are worried
about governments run amok.
So many people sort of do
take what you just said there,
that they hear a law and then
that in and of itself means
it must be just or right or something,
and then they just sort of acquiesce.
Do you think that is almost like a symptom
of the success of the West,
that we don't even know now
when tyranny is encroaching
on our lives like, okay, six months,
we're all gonna sit in
our house for six months,
40 million people will be unemployed,
the economy will be tanking.
And we're gonna all go, wait,
did anyone get sick?
Did anyone get sick?
- Yeah, no, I think that's a great point.
And I think some of it is.
There are a lot of people in this country
in our generation who've never,
they've never experienced a dictatorship.
They haven't experienced
any kind of tyranny.
A lot of us, obviously,
we lived through 911.
But we've been really
far removed, thankfully,
from a lot of really bad stuff
that previous generations have endured.
And so we don't really have anything
to compare it to.
And I think for some, they think,
"Oh, well, it's just temporary."
And isn't that kind of
how it always starts?
"Oh, it's just temporary,
"just a little bit of
our liberty for safety,"
which is a horrible trade off
and you never get a
return on your investment.
And with this, they think,
well, these are good people.
These are people we elected
that are telling us we need to stay home
and we need to listen to them.
And again, it goes back to just
because it's an executive order,
or it's a regulation
or it's a law.
That doesn't mean it's just.
It doesn't mean it's right.
And there are a lot of
conservatives, I have to say,
that are kind of going
along with this too,
which really surprises me.
Because these are people
who would complain against Red Flag Laws
and other forms of authoritarianism.
But with something like this,
I mean, they don't even
question what the trade-off is.
I mean, for instance,
what is flattening the curve?
Didn't we already flatten it?
So now we've gone from
flattening the curve
to we have to stay indoors
until there's a vaccine.
Well, no vaccine is ever 100% foolproof.
So what is the ultimate point here?
- Yeah, there's so much here.
That's actually an interesting
segue to your book,
because obviously you talk
a lot about outrage culture.
It's one of the things that
I talk about a lot too.
And I think partly what it is, with say,
the conservatives that
seemingly are giving over a lot
of their individual rights
to the government right now.
I think what it is
is that they're honestly
afraid of the outrage machine,
they're afraid to push a little bit
on the liberty side of things
or on the open up side,
because they don't want that mob
to come for them.
They don't want to be seen as,
oh, these, the way the media frames it,
that it's these fringe racist, right?
That was what CNN was saying about
the protesters in Michigan,
as if people were protesting for racism.
They wanted jobs, basically,
they wanted to live.
But I think that's what it is,
like you get sort of these
average conservatives
who I would agree on on a lot of things,
but then they're just like,
I don't want to push it
because I don't want the
thing to come for me.
And that's rarely how it works, right?
That policy doesn't work for too long.
- And liberty is not
something that's supposed
to be comfortable.
And that's the other thing.
I mean, it's not a guarantee of comfort.
And it's not a guarantee of happiness.
That doesn't mean that you're
gonna live a life completely
without any challenge
or any adversity.
That's not what freedom is.
I mean, freedom is the
ability to enjoy the fruits
of your labor and also the
consequences of your decision
and engage in free association.
Look, people were totally happy
when we were initially
told what, two weeks,
we would just like for you all
to kind of lockdown a little bit
and help us flatten the curve
so we don't overwhelm
the medical resources
and have like another Italy on our hands.
Everybody was more than happy to do that.
It wasn't because we were listening
to the government ordering us around.
It's because we generally care
about the lives and safety and wellbeing
of other people regardless
of what political identity they have.
And I mean, if you're gonna call yourself
a limited government person,
I think part of that
goes with understanding
that voluntary stewardship,
good stewardship goes
hand in hand with that.
And people didn't go out and protest
until you had some of these tiny tyrants,
I think as they've been
nicknamed across the country,
really exerting authority
that they didn't have
and they shouldn't have exerted
and really getting into the weeds with it.
Like burning seeds and saying,
you could take a kayak out on a lake,
but you can't take a boat with a motor
because apparently gas and
motors make the RONA grow,
I don't know,
and instituting like curfews
and all of this stuff.
And that's when people began
to rightfully question.
Okay, wait a minute,
we've been doing all of these,
what is the point?
And then the two weeks went
from two weeks to a month,
and then two months,
people just want to be told the truth,
and they want to feel as
though their elected officials
are being forthright with them.
And all of this showcase
something else entirely.
And so that's when people
started protesting.
And to point out, too, in Michigan,
you always have and as I understood it,
there were small group of people
who came out and decided
to be butt heads about it.
But that is not in any
way indicative of all
of the protests that have been
happening across the country,
even in California.
And for the media and others to focus
on that one incident as a way
to invalidate the other protest
is a really disingenuous way
of evaluating the concerns of real people.
And it just forces that chasm
between the sides apart further.
- Just to be clear, so the
incident you're referring to,
are you talking about all the guys
that were doing the open
carry in the state capitol?
Is that what you're
referring to specifically?
- They had so many show up
and they had like some signs
and then there was one that was a plant
where they had like,
what was it a Nazi flag,
and it turned out, it
ended up being a plant,
it was incorrectly reported or whatever.
I mean, all of that, the
theatrics and the messaging
and everything aside,
the fact that people
were were focusing more
on the protesters instead of
here you have elected officials
that are doing certain things
that they have no authority
in their state constitutions to do.
And they have the press,
which is supposed to be
the watchdog of the people,
not adequately or accurately reporting
on things for the people they
claim to care about so much.
That's a little frightening,
which is why I'm thankful
for citizen journalism,
but that was frightening
and that's a problem
and I think it just continues
to feed this distrust
that people have of authority, ultimately.
- Yeah, that's a good
segue also for something
that's in the book that
you are always hitting,
very much in line with
what I'm hitting on.
Let's talk about the press a
little bit, sort of mainstream.
Everyone's watching it collapse,
everyone's watching the quote, unquote,
journalist destroy journalism.
Does this thing just need to flame out?
If you would have asked
me maybe six months ago,
I was still on,
oh, this thing can be fixed wagon,
or at least that we should
still be trying to fix it.
And now after Corona,
I'm just like,
and after what Chuck Todd did
in the last couple weeks with Bob Barr,
and just like watching the rest of it,
it's like, you know what,
maybe just let it crumble.
And while I think there's
major risks on the other side,
if we have nothing that's mainstream,
it's like what gives us national cohesion?
It's like why are we saving this thing?
Are you in that space?
Or do you think there's
something worth saving
or some mix, maybe?
- Yeah, I think it's kind of a mix.
I don't ever think that the
press has been unbiased ever
even since its inception.
I mean, I think of the funny little ways
that they used to,
like during the days of our founding
that folks would go after each other,
politicians would write nasty editorials,
which were so much more
scandalous than some
of the stuff that we're seeing now.
- He's got syphilis.
It's like a whole bunch of crazy stuff.
- Like real colonial
housewives come to life.
That's what it seemed like,
it was so crazy.
I don't think that they've
ever been unbiased.
I do think that they maybe
perhaps have been a little bit
more attentive to the needs of the people
because at one point,
the press was the people,
the press and the people
kind of were hand in hand,
and the press was the people's way
to keep check on their government.
And now, it's dissolved
into party allegiances.
And a lot of the press,
and there have been surveys,
the majority of them identify politically
one way as opposed to the other.
And I don't even have a problem with that.
The problem that I have is the egos
of so many of these
individuals who seem to think
that the byline isn't
the most important thing
on a piece,
as opposed to the information
that the piece is sharing
and or supposed to share.
And so many of these Q&As
with the president turn into
some kind of footage
for a reporter to aggrandize themselves
and make a story out of themselves
or it's all prop, it's
political propaganda.
And it's frustrating
because I always feel,
a free press is a sacred thing.
And I will defend that to the end.
But are they free, though,
when they cannot report on things outside
of that political filter,
when everything has to run
through that party affiliation?
Is that really free reporting?
And I also think that
criticism of the press seems
to be taboo now.
But a lot of people in the
press don't seem to understand
that a free press and
a free people's right
to criticize their free press,
these are things that go hand in hand,
you can't have one without the other.
And you can't criticize
our criticism of you
without kind of ultimately
betraying your principles.
Like I said, I don't mind
bias when it's honest.
But I don't want people
to report something
and have it be politically one sided
and then try to rely on the credit earned
by a previous media generation back
when they at least attempted to not place
so much emphasis on the byline,
or who was anchoring the news
at that particular point.
I wish that they would just
focus on the information.
And if they want to do
editorial, do editorial.
Like I'm not a journalist,
I'm not a hard reporter.
I am an editorialist,
commentator, an analyst.
I am so biased, it's crazy,
but I admit it,
and I'll be honest with people about it,
but I want them to do the same as well.
Just be honest about it.
- Do you think people get confused
when people attack the media?
There seems to be this idea
that if people like you
and I attack the media,
that somehow we're part of the problem.
Or the other version of this is like
when Trump fights with everyone at CNN,
he's fighting with Jim Acosta.
And people are like,
he's attacking the press.
And it's like, well,
I actually have no problem with that,
he has first amendment rights, too.
Now if he was using the power
of the government, obviously,
to silence them,
well, now we got a problem.
But he, as far as I know,
he's not doing that.
Yet they love to play the victim too.
And it's like, what happens
in America constantly,
is that everyone is exercising
their free speech all the time.
I mean, we could get to
the big tech problem,
maybe in a moment,
but like that the way
it actually is working,
Trump fighting with them,
them attacking Trump,
us attacking them,
you may not love the whole game,
and it may be something
that burns too hot,
so it's eventually gonna
explode or something.
But like everyone's free speech
is being protected basically.
- No, I think that's a good point.
I mean, isn't that what it's all about?
I mean, America has always been kind of
like a big giant family
arguing at the dinner table.
And it makes it infuriating,
but also amazing.
I mean, I wouldn't
change it for the world.
And that's what it's supposed to be like,
but this idea that if you criticize
the press for bad reporting,
and there are numerous
examples of bad reporting.
There are entire media
entities on the right
that exist to document legitimate
cases of bias reporting.
And that's not attacking anyone,
they act like they're on a battlefield
and as they're trying to eat their MRE,
they're being hit with
missiles from the President
or from a Republican or whatever,
because they dared to write a bad story.
And that's the point of it.
It's like we also in addition
to keeping our politicians honest,
we have to keep our press honest.
And I feel like we were sold a bad,
that was a bad sale.
Like we were supposed
to have them as an ally
instead of now because
really there are a lot
of people in the press,
and I know you would agree with this,
that have really abused
their position of power.
And it is a position of power.
I will never forget the
story of this elderly lady,
and I wrote about it in my book,
this elderly woman who
had a Facebook group
that was a pro Trump Facebook group.
I mean, she can do whatever she wants,
she can play FarmVille,
she can do a pro Trump Facebook group.
And CNN showed up at her house
and they did a story on her.
Her address was displayed on camera
and she ended up getting threats.
And I'm thinking
because you don't like
a political affiliation,
you decide to abuse
your authority as a way
to really intimidate
people into not engaging
in a right that they have.
That's bothersome.
I've been the victim of press bias.
You've been the victim of press bias.
I don't think there's anyone that is
in this industry that
hasn't been affected.
But the idea that any kind of criticism
of them means that they
are being persecuted,
I would have to say, well,
there is a definitive history as to
who started what.
And it wasn't the people
who attacked an unbiased press.
It was the people who started pointing out
some really unfair and nasty articles
that had been written.
So I don't give a lot of credence.
And when they're unfairly attacked,
I'll definitely speak up.
But not every one of
those attacks are unfair,
or criticisms are unfair.
- So that's actually a perfect segue
to the outrage part of this.
So as I'm doing all my press for my book,
one of the things that people
are asking me constantly
is when did the outrage thing start?
Is there a moment that you can point to
that it started.
I have a couple different answers for it,
'cause I think there's a few
things that led up to it.
But do you see like a moment
or a political movement or a person
that sort of got us into this
mess that now we all see?
- Oh, that's a good question,
because it feels like people
have been outraged for so long.
Even since the George W. Bush years,
even maybe even going back to Reagan,
people have been outraged for a long time.
I remember going,
the first time I was ever
at the Reagan Library,
and I was looking at one of the exhibits
and it was about some of the media bias
towards Reagan and those
headlines were nasty.
And he would say one thing
or look one particular way
and there were headlines about it.
I do think that it's grown
to include almost every aspect of life.
So instead of it just being a
reaction, it's now a culture.
And when that occurred,
I don't know, maybe sometime
after George W. Bush,
it's one of those things where
it's been around for so long,
we don't realize that we are in it,
we don't realize how
long we've been in it.
When do you think it started?
- So I have a couple of
different answers on this
but i think,
you know my story, so as a lefty,
I was very much in like
the progressive thing
and I think it was sort of
the first time Bernie came around.
He ignited,
although I don't think
he himself was realizing
what he was doing exactly.
He ignited this like thing
that was laying underneath this,
like there was tinder
basically underneath,
that he ignited that sort of
everything in America was bad.
And that once you do that,
you couple that with identity politics,
you couple that with 20
years or almost three decades
maybe of kids being told
that they can never lose
and their feelings matter
and participation, trophies,
and basically all of these things,
that then as we became
more hyper partisan,
and then you finally,
you throw Trump onto it,
which I think he was
just the symptom of it,
not the cause of it.
But that I think is why
the last five years,
oh, and then of course, you
throw social media into it.
So I don't know that
there's an exact moment,
but it was like hyper
partisan leftyness coupled
with sort of the collapse
of the decent liberal,
you throw in social media,
you throw in trolls,
you throw in bots,
you throw in Trump who
wants to play that game.
You throw in the dishonest media
and it was almost like
we summoned this thing.
We all sort of did it together.
I don't point to like, oh,
it was April 25th, 2007.
- We summoned a monster.
It is very much a Frankenstein's
monster kind of story.
And you're right, social
media intensifies it,
it's the magnifying glass
through which the sun's rays are leveled
at some of our fellow ants.
I mean, that's really
ultimately what it's like.
I definitely think that
the Bernie thing ushered in
the whole outrages of culture
because it existed as a tactic,
and I remember even seeing it during
the Occupy Wall Street days.
But definitely with the introduction
as not just a Bernie
Sanders but of socialism
as now kind of like a
legitimate spring off
of the Democrat Party,
or really ultimately
what the Democrat Party
is now, it really hasn't taken over.
And there isn't a good,
what happened to the liberals?
Where did the liberals go?
Where did those liberal
that were Democrats,
like even the Joe Manchin's kind,
I mean he seems like a decent guy.
I disagree with him on a
number of policy issues.
But he seems like a decent guy, right?
He's not a nasty person.
He really focuses on policy,
but he's like a dinosaur
in the Democrat Party.
It's not cool to be kind.
I mean, it really isn't, it's not.
I mean that's true.
- As I said to you on
your show the other day,
they basically executed
Order 66 on the liberals.
The progressives saw the soft
underbelly of liberalism,
liberals are nice, liberals are tolerant,
liberals are decent,
but that's the good
stuff about liberalism.
But what comes with that
is this open mindedness
where we'll let anyone in
and the progressives were like,
oh, we're gonna do it
in the name of tolerance
and decency and diversity,
but actually destroy the whole thing.
- They turned into the biggest
Puritans also ironically.
So there are such an odd,
all their belief systems
are this weird dichotomy
and I can't mix for that.
And it's very inconsistent,
which makes me question the authenticity.
- It's the anti-racists
who are the racist.
It's the people who say, yeah,
they flip everything on its head.
It's sort of bananas.
One of the things that I like
that you do when I follow you on Twitter,
you're on the shortlist of people
who don't make me completely
insane on Twitter.
But you get a lot of hate.
We all get hate, okay, we
subject ourselves to it.
But sometimes people will
say quite horrific things
about you, your family, your kids,
your husband, the whole thing,
and you'll just retweet
them and say, God bless,
or I don't agree,
something like that.
Do you think that
ultimately that is the key
to winning this thing, so to speak,
if there's a win,
which is sort of just be a little better.
That's kind of the message that I try
to push to college students is,
I know it's not easy,
because it sucks and nobody
wants to be called these things,
but just be a little bit better.
- It's not easy,
and it's not rewarded
with clicks or likes.
And it really goes,
you won't get it. You don't
get anything out of it.
Everybody likes treating
politics like it's a gladdie,
it's like a gladiator event.
And I used to not always
be that way, admittedly.
I mean, I have always
kind of been a brawler.
Even when I was a Democrat,
I was always kind of a brawler,
and I was the person
who would crash protests
in college and I would just
even if it was just myself,
I would go and crash protests
and do all kinds of stuff.
But I also think to at a certain point,
you sort of realize, well,
you ask yourself rather,
why are you doing what you're doing?
Are you out here to
win just this argument?
Or are you out here to like plant a seed
into someone's mind.
Because you really, truly
want to change something.
And I think for the people
who really want to and
truly want to change things
and do have the best
interests of others at heart,
they realize that this is not
gonna be an immediate thing.
No one is going to ever have
their minds changed on Twitter.
No one's ever gonna have their
minds changed on Facebook,
or in a five-minute cable news discussion
where people are yelling over each other.
It's just entertainment.
It's infotainment.
That's all it is.
The real heavy work comes
from repeated interaction
and not just through the keyboard either.
And I used to, well, my
friend and I used to work
for Andrew Breitbart
before he passed away,
he would retweet all the hateful stuff.
And he would engage with a lot of it too,
but he had fun doing it.
And initially, I retweeted it,
because it did make me mad.
And I wanted to hurt the other person
and I wanted to make fun of them.
And I wanted to just destroy
them on a public level
where they would just be nothing
but a smoking pile of ash.
And then after a while, I'm like,
what's the point of that? For
real, what is the point of it.
Because one more person that
I'm able to break through to
and actually have a conversation with
and maybe get them to agree
with me on 80% of this stuff,
that's like one less person
that I have to fight,
or that is gonna make bad policy,
when my kids get older
and they're gonna have to deal with it.
And then I started thinking,
I don't want my kids to have to deal
with a Frankenstein's monster
that I participated in creating.
So what can I do to make that different?
It wasn't one certain thing
that changed my thinking
on dealing with the hate aspect of it,
it was a bunch of stuff.
And then when I tell people God bless,
it may look like I'm being smart aleck,
but I'm really not.
I mean, I'm really not wishing
ill will towards any of them.
Because who knows, I mean,
maybe some of them would have
been me like 15 years ago,
and they just haven't had that moment
where they figured out
how to really get in there
and really, truly engage and advocate
for what they believe in.
And I think that that's a journey
that every single person
is on and people come
to different realizations
about it at different times.
- Yeah, so you've probably loved the fact
that I haven't really brought
up guns with the gun lady,
but let's do a little bit.
Let's do a little bit on guns.
I'm sure I'm not the first
person to refer to you
as the gun lady, right?
That the gun lady seems like.
They probably have different
adjectives before gun lady.
There's probably some other
adjectives they put in there.
- And lady also is interchangeable.
- Touche, touche.
Okay, so we actually don't
have to do a ton on it
because you spent so much
time talking about this stuff.
But can we do like two or three things
that you would love to explain
to, say, anti-gun people
or two or three things
that are like the memes
that are just misunderstood
about our laws or about
the Second Amendment?
Just a couple things that
we could maybe clean up.
Because I think you've had
to spend a lot of time doing
that sort of thing.
There was that infamous CNN
Town Hall after Parkland,
and that was just a absolute fiasco,
but maybe just a couple other things
that people should know,
that maybe they don't fully
grasp or something like that.
- Yeah, no.
I think the biggest thing
is a lot of people think
that they're anti gun, but they're not.
They're really not.
They are anti you having a gun,
because they don't trust themselves.
And because they don't trust themselves
and they don't have confidence
in their ability to handle it,
they project that onto other individuals.
I always tell people,
if you're anti gun,
then you really don't believe in,
I mean, you shouldn't
believe in calling the police
to come with their guns
if you have a need,
where firepower is required as a solution.
You shouldn't hire private
security if you're anti gun.
And I think that the idea of well,
I'm okay with guns so long
as private security has them
or police have them.
And there was a guy who,
actually this was a couple of weeks ago,
who on Twitter was telling me,
"Oh, yeah, I work for the
firm that Moms Demand hires
"whenever they have events,"
and I've had Moms Demand
in every town confirm
this to me separately from this.
But you're hiring
private security for you,
but you don't want other
individuals to have that access.
I don't want to outsource
the carrying of my firearm,
and that seems really classist.
If we're to have a discussion
about legitimate class warfare,
I would think the idea that
only people wealthy enough
to hire private security to protect them,
that is incredibly classist,
because not everybody has Bloomberg money,
not everybody is in that position.
And so if you're truly anti gun,
then you would believe that
for police and military
and everything else.
It's not a little bit of a position.
That's one of the areas
that I think is either or.
And there are very few
areas where there really
isn't a lot of nuance.
I think that an abridgment
of a natural right
is a denial of a right.
That would be the first thing.
And the second thing is that
we've always had firearms,
and we have more laws
now than we ever had.
And we have seen only in
terms of youth acting out
in ways where they shouldn't
and accessing firearms.
I think that we're ignoring
a really serious problem
in our society,
with younger people, with
young males particularly.
And I know you've talked about
this before on your program,
a lot of people have discussed this,
Jordan Peterson has talked about this.
This is not getting enough attention.
And I'm a boy mom.
And I can see how easy it is for young men
to go off the rails.
And young women can too.
But there's something
different with young men,
and it's really easy for
them to go off the rails.
And it's almost,
we're in a society that is,
in my opinion, is hostile
towards young men,
and all young men,
and then it gets into varying
degrees of severity depending
on different boxes checked.
All of that is just making
a kindling for this problem.
And until we deal with that,
we're always gonna have these problems.
But you're not gonna solve it
by punishing law abiding
people who are not the fuel
for this problem.
And then I guess the last thing,
all of the laws that people keep saying
that we need, we have.
I mean, every single day.
- That was the one I really
wanted you to hit, yeah.
- Yeah.
Every single day I see
somebody propose something
and they're like, oh, well,
we shouldn't have crazy people
that can buy guns.
Okay, well, you can have someone committed
or you can request,
there's a whole way to go about this
that preserves due process
and protects innocent people.
The Red Flag Law terrifies me.
And because it's a removal of due process.
Red Flag Laws aren't even about guns.
Red Flag Laws are a complete
removal of due process.
Guns are a variable in the situation.
And when people realize that,
that a firearm is a variable,
and when you set this precedent
of completely obliterating
someone's ability
to have that protection of due process,
you are gonna be able to accuse people
and convict them before a
trial on any number of things.
This isn't just about guns.
Think of an issue.
And that to me is a
terrifying beginning to full.
That's a terrifying concept.
The fact that some are so
incredibly lackadaisical about it,
they're willing to remove that pin
of our republic just to what,
because they think they're gonna cancel
out Second Amendment.
That's a horrible way to do it.
- Do you think that
the real tough part is,
well, you got to explain some truth,
okay, so that's tough.
But the left generally is much better
at the bumper sticker answers.
And that is usually what people
who aren't really
thinking want to swallow.
I mean, the easiest version of this
is when I go to my local supermarket,
there is a sign on the outside
and has a gun and it's crossed out
and says this is a gun free zone.
And if you're an average lefty,
I think you walk in there and
you're like, you feel good.
You're like, "Oh, well,
there'll be no guns in here.
"That's fantastic."
And of course,
all you have to do like
most things, unfortunately,
that come out of the
left these days is think
about it for about six to eight seconds
and usually what you'll find is,
"Oh, the bad guys, they
probably don't pay attention
"to the stickers,"
but to do what you just did
there takes a lot more time,
takes more attention, takes
more work and knowledge
rather than here's a sticker on the door.
I feel good about it, do you?
- Yeah, well, and the
stickers don't create
this like invisible force field,
like that Star Trek
technology does not yet exist
in our world.
Or maybe it does and
we just don't know it.
Maybe that's what those
UFO videos are about.
It doesn't prevent bad guys
from coming into the area.
They're not gonna show up illegally
in possession of a firearm.
And I hate the phrase illegal guns.
It's always illegal possession.
They're not gonna show up
with an illegally possessed gun and go,
"You know what, I was gonna go in here
"and do some really shady stuff."
But this sticker, no, I'm
not totally on the sticker.
That's never happened.
And John Lott who is a
walking encyclopedia,
he's done a lot of research on
this. And I think what is it,
like the vast majority of
mass casualty incidents,
these mass shootings that have taken place
from the period of 1953
till current time have been
in gun free zones.
And a lot of these gun free zones,
they don't even have
armed security to protect
or at least try to protect the people
that they allow to come in.
So that is like Linus' blanket.
It's a safety blanket.
This idea of a gun-free anything,
why don't you just put a sign up
that says crime free.
Is some crime acceptable to you?
Just put a crime free zone sticker,
it's never worked.
We live in a reality where,
and this is why I think
some freedom scares people.
Some people cannot handle freedom
because they don't, I
think, trust themselves
and they don't trust other people.
And there are going to be people
that are going to abuse their freedom.
And even after they have been caught
and they have faced justice
and they have been punished,
they're still going to reoffend
and they're still going
to choose to do bad things
with their freewill.
You're never gonna be able
to legislate evil away,
because you cannot legislate
that away in each individual.
And the solution isn't to
remove people's ability
to defend themselves.
The solution is to make criminals afraid,
with more severe penalties instead of,
I mean, I could sit here and talk to you
about our justice system on and on and on,
because I think we have a massive problem
and we have too many felonies
and some of the non violent,
it just goes on and on.
But for the serious offenders,
there needs to be penalties
that really are adequate deterrence,
and quit punishing the law abiding
for what these people choose to freely do.
And I always tell people,
there are no such thing as loopholes.
It's like if someone is caught
driving under the influence,
they have their license suspended
and they continue going
and driving a vehicle,
they get caught.
That's not a loophole.
They're breaking the law.
That's a criminal act.
So these loopholes that
people keep talking about,
there's criminal acts
and non-criminal acts.
There's no nuance there.
The ATF has things covered to the point
of being over covered.
So there's a criminal act,
and then there's a non-criminal act,
there's no loophole.
- We always hear about
the gun show loophole.
- I know the gun show loophole,
because you always have gang members
they have going out there
and buying super expensive
collector's guns,
and then going out and
committing all of these crimes
with collector's items.
And even that is even,
even private sales are regulated
to a point and the penalty
on that is incredibly high.
But that's not how,
I mean, gangbangers, they've
done surveys on this,
people who are committing
crimes are getting this
off the black market.
And if you think you're gonna
eradicate the black market,
I mean, look how well the
war on drugs has gone.
You think that this is
gonna be any different.
I mean, it's the same
thing, different variable.
- Are you hopeful for
America at this point,
like we can talk about all the scary stuff
and the frustrations and
young people have problems,
and the media is collapsing,
and it feels like our institutions
are crumbling and COVID.
And we don't have trusted
sources, like all of this stuff.
But I sense that underneath
that is some hope
or some grace.
- I like to market myself
as a perpetual cynic.
And I think it just comes
by way of being like,
young Gen X.
I just am a cynic.
And that's like the Gen X
thing, is to be cynical.
But I have a supreme
appreciation and fondness
for that crazy American spirit,
the spirit that drove people to go,
"Hey, let's just take a wagon and go out
"in the wilderness."
We have no idea what's gonna happen,
but we're just gonna just
create something out there.
It is an animating spirit of liberty
and it makes people courageous
and it has made this country
in such a short period of time,
this beacon on the hill,
this amazing thing.
And I'm hopeful because of that.
And I even think,
even with some of the progressives
out there, you'll notice,
they're critical of,
even though they're leftist,
and some of them are socialist,
and some of say that they're communists,
they're all pretty critical
of Communist China.
They're pretty critical of Xi Jinping.
So there is still something
in that American DNA
that is making them rebel against at least
somewhat against authoritarianism.
The news looks bad.
I just know that media
likes selling you bad news.
So I don't really pay
any attention to that.
But I'm hopeful because of the stuff
that I see in little bits
that doesn't get reported.
The story of the guy who goes around
and cuts the elderly people's yards
because they don't have
the means or ability
to do it themselves and I
see little bitty things.
Or even like the kids in California
when the city dump sand
in their skate park,
and they went out and
they cleaned the sand out
of the skate park.
It was one of the most
awesome things I've ever seen.
That kind of stuff, that's
what brings me hope.
And the smart aleckness of those kids,
that's what brings me hope.
I love that.
The idea, the two women
who got busted in Laredo,
and they ended up also getting freed
by Texas Supreme Court order.
They were cosmetologist doing
services in their homes.
They're doing speakeasies.
I mean, that's like a
prohibition era kind of thing.
I love it.
They were creative,
and they were going around the man,
that's an awesome thing.
And the fact that Greg Abbott now says
we can have home delivery of liquor kit.
That's amazing.
I think I've sent his office like a couple
of emails saying that's cool.
That will make this go away.
- I thought you were gonna say
a couple of cases of whiskey,
just a couple emails.
- Oh, man, no, you can go and get ,
what is it, one's a bourbon bloom kit
and then you can actually get
like frozen margaritas now.
And he's like,
"Yeah, we may not ever have
these regulations come back in,"
God bless Texas.
So there's a little goofy things
that I can point to, but ultimately.
I am hopeful,
it's hard to be a cynic when
you see that kind of stuff.
And I am hopeful.
And I know that there's enough
rabble-rousers out there
and smart asses out there who really just,
they give me hope.
I don't know how else to put it,
but they do.
- All right, well,
everyone can follow you
on Twitter at Dana Loesch.
And in the words of
Dana Loesch, God bless.
- There you go, God bless. (laughs)
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of non-stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.